you don't know like something you're
saying that you don't sometimes know
where it's gonna go but all of us have
no idea where it's gonna go but do you
offer I intend to keep it their way well
bugger I thought I was great I wonder
wait'll it out of him guys um do you
sometimes look at the speculation on the
internet and go oh my god how are they
coming up with these theories you know I
I did once upon a time a long long time
ago but I've given up doing that
actually they did the Internet Ice and
Fire Community Game of Thrones community
of course has grown hugely over the
years and like the series has it
actually began right here in Australia
the very first web site ever devoted to
the series was started by a guy named
Peter Gibbs who was called Dragonstone
and it was based here in Australia and
it was the first bulletin board where
people would post their theories and
discuss them and talk about who was the
favorite character or who would win in a
sword fight or you know what secrets
they thought I was hiding we're not
hiding and when that occurred and now
we're going back to I think around
1998-99 that this Dragonstone started I
did look at it I was very flattered to
have a website entirely can devote it to
fans discussing not fantasy in general
and not science fiction in general but
specifically the series that I was
working on and I read some of the
discussions but then it rapidly dawned
on me you know I should not be doing
this for one thing I don't want to
actually post there because the minute I
post there the free discussion among
fans who are all more or less equal ends
and it becomes instead everybody gather
around the author and ask him questions
and that's a distortion of what the
format can be I didn't want to do that
and the other thing is yes some of the
theories were incredibly wrongheaded and
amusing in that sense
some of them were clever and maybe I
hadn't thought of them but now I'm
saying you know that would be good idea
have you done that no I don't want to do
that either because that and you know
then I'm like taking ideas from from the
fan I don't want to I want this to be my
own ideas and then the other one was of
course some you know I have certain
things that I'm laying clues for that
they'll be revelations later on some
people had put together those clues even
as early as 1998 or adding things
together I said well what do what do I
do with that
what do I do with that yeah these people
have guessed the secret that I'm gonna
reveal in book 6 people have already
guessed that here and two is just out
you really have two choices there you
can ignore it and proceed with your plan
despite the fact that some people know
where you're going or you can get old
panicky and say oh my god they figured
it out I can't let that be I'll have to
change it I'll have to go in a different
direction and I think some writers do
that and I think that's always a mistake
yeah you know if you've planned your
book that the butler did it and then you
read an internet someone has figured out
that the butler did it and you suddenly
change in midstream and it was the
chambermaid who did it
then you screw up the whole book we
should get these just foreshadowing
early on and you've got these little
clues you planted now they're dead ends
and you have to introduce other clues
and you're retconning it's a mess so I
decided as early as dragons dragon
stones heyday and I think that site had
gone away by 2000 or so that I would
stay off the fan sites and let the fad
let those be for the fans that those be
for the readers let them argue their
theories whether they're right whether
they're wrong but I don't need to know
about that
one thing that people try to do on the
internet is they watch the show and then
based on what isn't included in the show
they assume that isn't important in the
books for example Jeyne Westerling
survives but Talisa doesn't now is that
a fool's errand yeah
it's again is it just people massively
overthinking everything
people do overthink a number of aspects
to this you know eye color
oh yes VAT and other things people
overthink my my own comments here I mean
we have some of you one doubtedly rush
home and and tweet or post on facebook
about this some of you are probably
tweeting even now and I will make some
joke or some offhand comment and and of
course what year it's being repeated in
tweeting and all that they they all of
the context and the tone of voice has
taken out of it and suddenly becomes
like a papal pronouncement we're going
over it oh you use this word instead of
that word that must mean this thing and
and it's it's a little kind of scary the
freight that can that can be generated
by some of that yeah but the the show
the show is the show and the books are
the books Dave and Dan are doing a great
job and they're doing a very faithful
thing but they're they're operating
under constraints that I don't have and
budget running time you know the
practicalities of production so there
are places where the two are going to
diverge and they are going to diverge
I'm not gonna I'm not going to once
again and go back and make the chamber
may do it said of the butler did it
because because of something David and
Dan and did in the show and and if there
are indeed at the end there are
differences well so be it there are in
virtually every movie that was every
every movie adapted from a book every
television series adapted from book
these differences exist you never get a
complete transliteration